worklist dr. Dominic West earned a
Golden Globe nomination for playing a
cheating husband we hate that who
complicates his family's life work big
time in the hit series the affair it's
on Showtime the division of CBS now he's
taking on the role of Jean Valjean and a
new ID a patient of Victor Hugo's
classic novel and there's a rabbit out
on masterpiece on PBS Paul Jean is
haunted by his past after serving 19
years in prison from stealing bread
David Oyelowo plays his nemesis who
wants to put him back behind bars I
believe most of us are capable of good
and evil and how we turn out depends on
our circumstances and how we are treated
and has your own experience led you to
that conclusion yes it has yes it does
Dominic West welcome table I love you
and David Oh yellow Oh together
boss great scenes you and mr. Oh yellow
Oh together welcome thank you very much
Thanks so I don't know where we should
start with the wire with the affair or
shall we just start with them is this
thought we limb is so you say it again
let me say so what I like about this is
that I've seen the play I've seen the
movie but is it okay is it okay to say I
think I like this the best and I feel
you get to get a more in-depth view of
all the different characters what do you
think
well that was reason I wanted to do it I
said because when it they first
approached me I said what's the point
there's a very successful film and
obviously very successful shows what's
the point of redoing this again and um
and then I read the book and I realized
there's so much more going on you can
fit into a musical and there's been
certainly a living memory that hasn't
been a long-form adaptation of the books
and you call Valjean one of the greatest
heroes in literature why well he's he he
scales he climbs up the side of houses
like Spider Man he fights like Iron Man
but none of those guys have ever done 20
years hard labor in a 19th century
French prison so he's tough you know
he's a tough strong man and
but what sort of more heroic about him
is his constant battle with himself to
be to be a loving compassionate person
who's been brutalized imprisoned and and
and he opens himself up to love and
compassion yeah so let's talk about the
affair that's please the showrunners on
twitter that the fifth and final season
was incredibly painful to write but very
worth it so what will happen with your
character this season well I was I was
thinking that he'd that narrowed
slightly found a comic edge which I'm
really pleased about in the first three
or four episodes he's quite funny and
now he's found thank God
a bit of wisdom he's been through the
mill obviously he's been to jail and
he's and he's found some sort of wisdom
in that then and so and I was hoping you
might lighten up a bit let me ask you
that times up movement has put a focus a
renewed focus on equal pay and and Ruth
Wilson your former co-star said publicly
she believed that she was paid less than
you how can men be part of a positive
discussion about equal pay well I I
suppose that wasn't why she left by the
way yeah I mean I I was completely
unaware of this issue and and I it's
easy for or was easy for actors like me
not to ever question the pay Adam and it
never occurred to me it's what your
agent does so I suppose what this has
done is made people like me aware of
that and and that we can be more
involved in the in the contract
discussions as well you know what else
you're the only one at the table that
has a castle in my backyard it's not the
same I don't even have a backyard
because I live in a New York high-rise
but you have this this castle and it is
available for rent series oh it is yeah
please come yeah yeah castle the west
coast of Ireland is very beautiful on
the banks of the River Shannon we're
very keen for people to come and stay
because obviously it costs a lot to keep
it going
ancestral farm
Walsh is in ballylongford that's next
door I know that's right thanks to us I
know what are coming to come to have a
family reunion right there yeah yeah
yeah there was just Mary Ellen Walsh got
on a boat and left her family behind and
maybe you'll give him a break on the
price nor and I would like to come to
just saying please go leymah is by the
way premieres this Sunday on masterpiece
on PBS